y hemos aprendido en otros vídeos que el
átomo está hecho de partículas
elementales más pequeñas lo que es
sorprendente ya que los átomos son
inimaginablemente pequeños esas
partículas son los protones que tienen
carga positiva los neutrones que tienen
carga neutra o que no tienen carga y por
último tenemos a los electrones que
tienen carga negativa
ahora la gran pregunta que tuvieron
físicos y químicos hace 100 años es cómo
se configuran estas partículas y se
dieron cuenta que la carga positiva se
concentra en el centro del átomo de
hecho la mayoría de la masa que está
hecha de los protones y los neutrones se
concentra en el centro entonces un
primer modelo de la estructura del átomo
tenía quizás los protones y neutrones en
el centro
digamos que hablamos de un típico átomo
de helio el cual tiene dos protones y
dos neutrones en el núcleo y por lo
tanto el núcleo se ve de esta forma
entonces los antiguos químicos y físicos
decían ok si los protones tienen carga
positiva y los electrones tienen carga
negativa entonces se atraen entre sí ya
que cargas supuestas atraen y cargas
iguales se repelen
tal vez el electrón que tiene carga
negativa órbita alrededor del núcleo del
mismo modo que un planeta orbita
alrededor de una estrella tal vez el
electrón tiene una órbita parecida a
ésta y si hablamos de un átomo neutro de
helio que tiene dos electrones y dos
protones entonces tal vez el otro
electrón órbita de esta forma estamos
intentando que tengan órbitas elípticas
o circulares esta es la idea de que los
electrones están en órbitas sin embargo
resulta que no es exactamente así los
electrones no están en órbitas elípticas
o circulares bien definidas de hecho en
un momento dado no necesariamente
permanece en un punto puede estar allí
pero existe una probabilidad de que esté
aquí
y una cierta probabilidad de que esté
acá am y una cierta probabilidad de que
esté acá o acá entonces para describir
dónde es probable que se encuentren los
electrones los físicos y los químicos
introdujeron la idea de orbitales la
mejor forma de pensar en los orbitales
es pensar en el átomo de hidrógeno
de hecho el mapa de los orbitales se
completa con el átomo de hidrógeno por
ser el átomo más simple entonces en un
átomo de hidrógeno en especial en el
típico isótopo de hidrógeno que se
encuentra en la tierra el núcleo no
tiene neutrones sólo tenemos un protón
simple en el centro y si tenemos un
átomo de hidrógeno neutro podemos pensar
en las probabilidades de la ubicación de
su único electrón en lugar de que órbita
el protón de esta forma podría estar
aquí o podría estar acá en
en todo podría estar allá en otro
momento o podría estar fuera de la
pantalla en algún momento pero es más
probable que esté en una cierta región
del espacio alrededor del núcleo y
podemos visualizar dónde es más probable
que esté diciendo ok
parece que el 90% del tiempo se
encuentra en una esfera que se ve algo
así pero una vez más puede estar aquí
puede estar acá puede estar acá puede
estar acá puede estar en cualquier lugar
pero nosotros queremos decir en dónde
está el 90% del tiempo esa es la forma
de pensarlo ahora una pregunta
interesante es qué pasa si le das a ese
electrón un poco más de energía bueno
qué significa energía
si pensamos en planetas rocas o
satélites que orbitan alrededor y les
proporcionamos más energía es decir les
damos un empujón podrían tener una
órbita más grande que se vea más o menos
así pero en la mecánica cuántica no se
trata de que las cosas sucedan
gradualmente algunas personas piensan
que cuántica significa pequeño o algo
así sin embargo realmente significa que
hablamos de paquetes discretos de
energía así que la física cuántica en la
química cuántica se agrega a una cierta
cantidad de energía a un electrón en
lugar de que el 90% del tiempo pueda
encontrarse en la primera capa en este
primer nivel energético podría saltar al
siguiente nivel energético oa la
siguiente capa ahora puede ser que el
90% del tiempo se encuentre en este
nivel de energético que estamos
dibujando y si le damos el estímulo
adecuado de energía
que solo un poco nos serviría para que
salta el siguiente nivel energético
entonces formarán estos patrones
extraños que parecen pesas el 90% del
tiempo estará en este tipo de orbital
que tiene forma de pesas solo lo estamos
dibujando en una dirección horizontal
pero puedes tenerlo en el eje vertical o
incluso en el eje de profundidad de esta
página y si seguimos agregando energía
seguiremos obteniendo más y más
orbitales de formas exóticas y si nos
preguntamos de dónde vienen estas formas
tenemos que pensar en las ondas estándar
esta es la mejor pista que puedo darte
en un nivel cuántico de hecho en todos
los niveles pero especialmente en un
nivel cuántico podemos ver que los
electrones tienen su propiedad de
partícula y onda
así que imagina algo parecido a una onda
estándar si tenemos una cuerda y la
sacudimos podemos obtener ondas estándar
que se ven así y si tenemos algún tipo
de membrana en dos dimensiones y
presionamos en un lado justo aquí si la
golpeamos como si fuera tambor entonces
esta parte bajará y esta parte subirá
así que cuando lo llevamos a tres
dimensiones obtenemos esta forma de
pesas y cuando agregamos más energía
obtenemos formas más y más y más
exóticas y sólo para imaginar cómo se
ven los primeros orbitales creados por
una computadora podemos verlos así
si tenemos nuestro electrón con la
energía más baja estará en lo que se
conoce como un orbital s este se llama
1s porque estamos en la primera capa o
primer nivel de energía que observa está
más cerca del núcleo y si agregamos más
energía el electrón saltará al segundo
nivel energético oa la segunda capa y el
orbital en este segundo nivel que será
un valor predeterminado ya que es la
energía más baja del segundo nivel y se
llama orbital 2s una vez más tenemos un
orbital esférico y es probable que se
encuentre más lejos que el primer nivel
y una vez más si agregas más energía
seguirás en el segundo nivel o capa pero
estarás en uno de estos orbitales que
tienen mayor energía podemos ver esto
como el orbital 2 p en la dirección x
este es el orbital 2 p en la dirección
que algunos llaman a este
px y a este 2pm y este es el orbital 2 p
en la dirección zeta 2 p z y los
orbitales siguen incluso existe un
orbital d en el tercer nivel y cuando
llegamos al cuarto tenemos un orbital
efe hasta ahora sólo hemos hablado del
hidrógeno si continuamos agregando más
energía es electrón que pasará en donde
podría estar este otro electrón en un
espacio de dos dimensiones como podemos
imaginar si tenemos dos electrones no es
exactamente lo mismo pero es una buena
aproximación podemos poner dos
electrones en este orbital 1s pero
después de eso puedes imaginar que los
electrones se repelen unos a otros
entonces el electrón va a estar aquí y
el tercer electrón que agregues va a
terminar en el orbital 2s es decir
estará en un orbital con un nivel
energético mayor
en el puede haber dos electrones
entonces podemos tener hasta cuatro
electrones entre 1s y 2 s pero el quinto
tendrá que ir a uno de estos orbitales p
ahora un último punto es estar seguro de
que entiendes la terminología de los
orbitales y los niveles o capas primero
tenemos la idea del nivel energético la
palabra a nivel también se conoce como
capa por lo tanto en este diagrama hemos
representado el primer nivel y también
hemos representado el segundo nivel este
es un nivel y todo este es otro nivel
ahora también escucharemos el término
sub nivel o sub capa y esto es lo que
representa la s p ode y eventualmente
efe este es el primer nivel y el primer
nivel o capa sólo tiene un sub nivel el
psuv nivel 1 s el psuv nivel 1 s sólo
tiene un orbital
una vez más el orbital 1 s para el
primer nivel el nivel el psuv nivel y el
orbital se refieren a la misma cosa
pero si vamos al segundo nivel es un
poco diferente si hablamos de sus
niveles en el segundo nivel tenemos
s&p este es un sub nivel y este es otro
sublime la viene el segundo sub nivel p
hay tres orbitales bueno hasta aquí
vamos a terminar este vídeo pero en el
siguiente
veremos varios átomos y pensaremos en su
configuración electrónica es decir donde
estarán sus electrones en cuál de estos
niveles sus niveles y orbitales es que
estarán